so
today we're going to um begin
by going over the calvin cycle which i
know
i went um quite quickly on just to
introduce it at the end of the last
lecture
and so we'll spend a little time there
first and then we'll move on to discuss
the main topic of today which is the
pentose phosphate
pathway but before we get there i just
want to remind you
about the calvin cycle which you'll
recall
happened in three phases so there was
the fixation
reduction and regeneration phases
and so remember fixation um was a
special reaction that occurs only in
photosynthetic organisms
catalyzed by rubisco ribulose 1-5
bisphosphate
carboxylase oxygenase where a ribulose
one five bisphosphate molecule
combines with co2 and then is split to
produce
two three phosphoglycerates this was the
reaction that calvin described
as the dark reaction that now bears the
name of this
as the as the calvin cycle once you get
those
two three phosphoglycerates you can then
enter them into gluconeogenesis this of
course happens in the stroma of the
chloroplast and eukaryotic
photosynthetic organisms and is exactly
the reactions for the
reduction phase that we learned about
for glycolysis or gluconeogenesis when
we described it at the beginning of the
course
and so that 3pg is turned into
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphates and
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
of course that has to go backwards
through the
um the phosphoglycerate kinase as well
as the three phosphoglycerate
step that are glyceraldehyde three
phosphate dehydrogenase step
that we learned about um when we
discussed glycolysis and gluconeogenesis
and so therefore costs atp
as well as uh need a source of electrons
to go through glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
dehydrogenase
and that those come from nadph when this
is occurring
in photosynthetic organisms and the
chloroplast
once you get these trioses of course you
can continue with gluconeogenesis
combine them at the aldolase step to
make fructose 1 6 bisphosphate
that can be take the phosphate off by
fppas to give you fructose 6-phosphate
that can then be isomerized to glucose
6-phosphate
which of course could be further remove
the phosphate and go to glucose
or be turned into glucose one phosphate
or whatever else
to build starch or another storage sugar
for the plant um
combine glucose and a fructose say to
make
um make sucrose table sugar
and so those reduction steps we didn't
spend a lot of time on because it's
really gluconeogenesis
with the use of nadph rather than nadh
as we described it
um when we described gluconeogenesis um
back at the early part of the course now
once you run this part of the cycle that
of course gives you glucose
but of course in order to net run this
as a cycle much like we saw for the tca
cycle that if this is going to run as a
cycle you need a source of carbon
acceptors for the next co2
anaplerosis that we described in the tca
cycle remember we needed
a source of oxaloacetate that could net
accept
the next acetyl coa to continue running
the cycle
same thing happens here you need a
source of ribulose one five disphosphate
so rubisco has something to add co2 to
and so anaplerosis of this cycle
involves regeneration of
ribulose one five bisphosphate and
that's the
confusing set of reactions that i
introduced last time that we'll spend
much more time talking about today and
so
effectively this comes from
both six and three carbon units so
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
and fructose 6-phosphate with a series
of
of two and three carbon swaps
that ultimately generate these three
pentoses xylose 5-phosphate ribose
5-phosphate
and another xylose 5-phosphate once you
have those
xylose 5-phosphate you can see differs
from ribulose 1-5-bisphosphate
by the stereochemistry at the three
position and so
an epimerase reaction can fix that
we talked about those earlier and then
of course you need to
phosphorylate the one position on the
sugar to give you
ribulose one five bisphosphate that's
how you deal with the two xylose five
phosphates
and ribose five phosphate of course you
need to
change it from the aldos to the ketose
so that's an isomerase reaction
plus a uh phosphorylation to give you
uh ribulose one five bisphosphate
now if you run this entire cycle if
you're going to
net generate a hexose glucose or some
other hexose to
for the plant to store um as a storage
sugar
of course if it's coming from co2 you
need to run the cycle six times to take
six co2s
and that generate one hexose
um that can be stored for later and so
i just want to start by showing you that
this
accounting can work
so if we start here at the top
with six ribulose one five
phosphates and add six co2 molecules
you're going to net generate 12
3-phosphoglycerates
those 12 3-phosphoglycerates
can be turned into of course
12 glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate so that's
going to cost
12 any 12 atps
and 12
nadphs from the light reactions in
photosynthesis and so now you have
12 glyceraldehyde 3-phosphates i'm going
to
divide them up in the following way if i
take
two of those and place them over here
then take the remaining 10
use five of those here and turn five
more
into dihydroxyacetone phosphate
so that gives me five plus five plus two
equals twelve
total of these five glyceraldehyde three
phosphates and five dihydroxyacetone
phosphates
i can run them through the aldolase step
to generate
five fructose one six bisphosphates
turn those 5 fructose 1 6 bisphosphates
into 5 fructose 6
phosphates and of course i need one of
those
to ultimately generate a glucose
6-phosphate or
whatever hexose then i'm going to have
as my
net product if i do that that leaves me
four left over and so i'm going to
allocate them such that i have
two here and two here
all right so the two i have here can be
combined with the remaining two
glyceraldehyde three phosphates
to generate two xylose five phosphates
and two erythros four phosphates
a five carbon sugar and a four carbon
sugar
this five carbon sugar this xylose five
phosphate i can then use a primary
and atp so that's two atps
running back through and that's going to
net give me
two ribulose one five bisphosphates
which i'll draw up there later
coming back down here i have this two
erythros4 phosphates
and two fructose six phosphates if i do
a
three so this was a two carbon swap so i
took the two carbons
um for this step to generate the xylose
five phosphate and erythrose4 phosphate
i took two carbons from fructose
6-phosphate
added them to glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
that's why i got the 5-carbon
xylose 5-phosphate and that left me
with a 4-carbon erythrose4-phosphate so
all the carbons add up
now i take this four carbon erythrose
four phosphate and
uh the two remaining fructose six
phosphates
and if i move three carbons from here
to there what i end up getting is a
seven
carbon cetaheptulose seven phosphate
and a three carbon glyceraldehyde
three phosphate and so
two in two out now i'm going to move two
carbons again two carbons from the
cedaw7 phosphate to the glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate
um and that's going to give me 2
7 minus 2 is 5. 3 plus 2
is 5. so two five carbon sugars two
ribose five phosphates and two xylose
five phosphates
xylose five phosphates through the
epimerase
costing me two atp ribose biphosphate
through
isomerase costing me two atp
and what i net generate is two ribulose
five phosphates here two ribose five
phosphates there two rabulos five
phosphates there
two plus two plus two equals six and so
i
by running this cycle six times six
ribulose one five bisphosphates in six
co2 in two
or sorry six ribulose one five
bisphosphates out
and one hexose out
so all the accounting adds up
i know there's a lot of moving pieces
there
it's confusing but we'll see as we go
through today
why it works this way however before we
get there
i just want to stress what um
what we've actually accomplished here
okay so
basically we started with
six co2 molecules
and we added to that
12
nad phs and so those 12 nadphs
came there through the atp
sorry through the 3-phosphoglycerate to
generate the glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
so running through the gap dh reaction
using nadph
and so we had to do that 12 times plus
a total of 18
atp molecules and so 12 of them
up there through the phosphoglycerate
kinase step cost me 1280 please plus i
needed an additional
six atps to regenerate the
ribulose one five bisphosphates to
re-phosphorylate
the six pentoses that i generated
um through the regeneration phase of the
calvin cycle
and so that's 12 plus two plus two plus
2 or 12
plus 6 equals 18. um and
what i net generate is
one
glucose molecule from my
six co2 and of course to do this i
needed a lot of energy input
that comes from the 12 nadphs and the 18
atps
which of course are the products
of the light reactions
of photosynthesis
okay and so you'll recall that if we go
back
to our chloroplast right
the light reactions are happening here
at the thylakoid membranes
of the chloroplast and that's where
we're generating our atp
and our nad ph from the light reactions
and then here in the stroma of the
chloroplast
is where we're doing the dark reactions
and so
perfectly position where the atp and the
nadph from the light reactions
are there to fuel the dark reactions the
calvin cycle
and net have this turn co2 and generate
a pentose glucose fructose
combine them to make a sucrose or a
bunch of glucose that we can build
as alpha 1-4 polymers to make
starch depending on the organism and how
it chooses to
um to store its its sugars
okay so that is the
calvin cycle but what i want to do now
is
look a bit more closely on why it works
this way that is
why nature chose this confusing system
with two and three carbon swaps wouldn't
it just have been easier to just
i don't know take luke take co2s and
build a glucose molecule
together well of course the reason it
does this has to do with the chemistry
of how the reactions happen
and if we look more closely at
the various steps and these these swaps
that take place
in the regeneration phase
so
basically what we see is in
every single situation so it's basically
this reaction
this reaction and this reaction which
are the
swap part of the regeneration phase
you see that in every case we're moving
two carbons
um and so here two carbons were moved
from fructose
six phosphate to glyceraldehyde three
phosphate
so six minus two equals four
three plus two equals five that's how we
get erythros4 phosphate and xylose
5-phosphate
here we started with our
fructose-6-phosphate and our erythros-4
phosphate
moved three carbons from here to there
so six minus three three equals
three four plus three equals seven
okay so that's a three carbon swap and
then here again is another two carbon
swab so three carbon glyceraldehyde
three phosphate
seven carbon cetoheptulo seven phosphate
move two carbons from here to there
seven minus two is five
three plus two is five and that's how we
get um
those two pentoses now if we look more
closely at this what you'll see in every
case
the swap involves a a
ketose and an aldose so here we have
fructose 6-phosphate it's a ketose
here we have glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
it's an aldose
and what we end up with is a the
aldos getting longer by two carbons
to become a ketose and the ketos getting
shorter
by two carbons to become an aldos same
thing happens here
here we have a ketose and an we do the
swap
we have the aldos getting longer by
three carbons
to become a ketose and the
ketos becoming shorter by two carbons i
sorry three carbons in this case
to become an aldos and lastly same swap
we showed before
here we have an aldose i'm sorry a
ketose and an aldose
the ketos gets shorter by
two carbons to become
aldose and the aldos gets longer
by two carbons to become a
ketose
so i recognize that it's very hard to
follow that when i'm saying aldos and
ketos over and over and over again
but effectively in every single case
what we're doing
is we're moving
two carbons or three carbons
and we're moving them from
a ketose to
an aldos okay and so that means that
our product when we do that
is we end up getting a longer
ketos okay so
our former aldos
plus two or plus three
carbons
becomes a longer ketose and then we end
up getting
a shorter
aldose
from the former ketos
minus two or minus three
carbons okay so if you go and look at
that
you will see in every single case where
we're doing those two and three carbon
swaps
we're effectively following that
rule so these
reactions which i've abbreviated up
there
are catalyzed by enzymes
called tk
which stands for trans
ketolace or ta
which stands for trans
aldolase okay
tk transketolase ta
transaldolase
i want to point out that these are the
enzymes that catalyze the transketolase
is going to catalyze the two carbon
swaps and the transalva lace
is going to catalyze the three carbon
swaps okay and so twice we use
trans-keto lace once we use
transaldolase
transketolace move the two carbons
from the um ketos to the aldos giving
you
a longer ketose and a shorter
aldose and transaldelase also
catalyzed this case a three carbon swap
um
giving you a longer ketose and a shorter
aldose following the exact same rules
now these enzymes
is why it works this way and i want to
point out that the enzyme names
are absolutely not helpful for
remembering what they do
both enzymes use a keto stoner and an
aldos
acceptor both generate products
where the former aldos becomes longer
as a ketose and the former ketos becomes
shorter
as an aldos all right so don't rely
on the enzyme names to remember
what they do you'll see partially why
they're named what they are as we go
through the mechanisms
but for now just remember that
transketolase two carbons transaldolase
three carbons okay different numbers of
carbons moved
but always give you um
follow the exact same rules
i know this is confusing and so it's
probably better to go through
exactly what is going on
using a couple examples
all right so let's start off here with
a
ketose
okay so here is a ketose this is of
course
fructose 6-phosphate okay
and so fructose-6-phosphate is a ketose
we use this step here as an example
fructose-6-phosphate
and glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate okay so here we start with
our
ketose
and if we also use with it
a
aldose
okay so this one here is
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate which of
course in aldos
okay so if we
subject this to a trans-keto lace
reaction
which remember is moving two carbons
all right we're going to take the two
carbons from the ketose
and move them to the aldos
all right so if we do that
what we end up with is if we take two
carbons from here we end up with a
shorter aldose
and we end up with a
longer ketose
all right so trans-keto lace reaction
ketos donor of two carbons
give them to analdos acceptor of two
carbons
that gives me an aldose that's
shorter minus two carbons so
the bottom four carbons from fructose
6-phosphate
now become erythros4-phosphate analdos
and here we have our aldos accepts
the two carbons and so now we generate a
ketose
that is longer by two carbons
and that gives me this uh um
this longer ketose so
um in this case xylose 5-phosphate okay
so this is
the exact trans-ketolace reaction that
is right there this first part fructose
6-phosphate glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
give me an erythrose4 phosphate and a
xylose
5-phosphate okay so two carbons move
from a ketose to an aldose gives me a
shorter aldose
and a longer ketose all right
now if we do exactly
the same thing but this time rather than
do
a trans-keto-lace reaction do a
transaldolase reaction
so now i'm going to move three carbons
so
same thing keto stoner aldos
acceptor all right so now i'm going to
end up if
i donate three carbons from that ketose
what i end up with is
three carbons remaining
okay
and if i start with this
three carbon as an acceptor move three
carbons over
now i end up with a longer ketose
you
okay and so
all right so instead do a transalva lace
reaction
take three carbons from the ketos
transfer them to the aldos that means
the ketose now gets
shorter by three carbons and becomes an
aldose
and the former aldos gets longer by
three carbons
and becomes a ketose and so if i use
these two things as substrate fructose
6-phosphate and glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate
what do i generate i generate another
glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate and a fructose-6-phosphate
where all i do is scramble
which carbons are where and so this
obviously is not
a reaction i showed for how you do
anaplerosis of the calvin cycle
but clearly can happen these
transketolase and transaldolase enzymes
are
highly reversible and so this is
of course is happening scrambling
carbons around
but there's no net generation or
consumption of anything because
of course we're just moving carbons
between a ketosis and aldos generating
the same ketos and the same aldos using
these particular substrates
but if we look at how it worked
where we showed it here fructose
6-phosphate erythrose4 phosphate
we end up moving those three carbons
onto erythrose4-phosphate that gives us
acetohepro7-phosphate
and leaves us with a shorter aldose
glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate okay and so
i color-coded the carbons here to show
how transketolase and transaldolase work
and if you go back over here through the
calvin cycle
you will note that every single
one of the reactions where i drew
transketolase and transaldolase
follows those exact rules
okay so why does it work this way well
it works this way because
of how transketolase and transaldolase
work as enzymes and so as
i said at the beginning to the of the
course and have now alluded to
several times is that biochemistry is
just nature repurposing
the same chemistries the same reactions
with slight variations over and over and
over again
to build that complexity and i think
that is
very evident here okay so a lot of
complexity in what we described
but it's really just using two enzymes
transketolase and transaldolase
and transketolase and transaldolase
basically use variations on chemistry
that we've already seen
to catalyze these reactions which is
almost certainly
why it evolved this way because you
already have a reaction that catalyzes
something
you tweak it and now you can get these
swaps and
nature figures out away to have it work
all right and so what are those
reactions so
transketolase which remember catalyzes
the two carbon
movement okay that's two carbons that
are moving
it uses tpp
plus so that's remember thiamine
pyrophosphate
we saw it before it was involved in
those
decarboxylation reactions of alpha-keto
acids
okay we saw it in the pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction to turn pyruvate
into acetyl-coa we saw it in ethanol
metabolism
to turn pyruvate into acetaldehyde and
we saw it in
the tca cycle to turn
alpha-ketoglutarate
into into succinate
and in all those cases we decarboxylated
that is broke a carbon-carbon bond of an
alpha um keto acid
and that used tpp plus
and basically what happens in the
trans-keto-lace reaction
is tpp plus is also used to break a
carbon-carbon bond
but this time rather than releasing co2
it's basically
moving the two carbon unit over to
another molecule as i'll show in a
minute
transaldolase which remember
moves three carbons does not use tpp
plus
instead it uses an aldolase
like mechanism
to move the three carbons and so
aldolase you remember if you think way
back to when we described glycolysis
aldolase broke the carbon-carbon bond to
take you from
fructose 1 6-bisphosphate to
glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate and dihydroxyacetone
phosphate
and so that was done with an active site
lysine
and transaldolase basically repurposed
that reaction also has an active site
lysine
breaks a carbon-carbon bond but this
time to transfer the three-carbon unit
from a keto stoner to an aldos
acceptor and when we go through the
mechanism you'll see it will be
very reminiscent of if you look back in
your notes
how aldolase worked in glycolysis
all right so let's start with
the mechanism
of trans-keto lace
okay so trans-keto lace
uses thymine pyrophosphate
okay so remember this here is the
active part of thiamine pyrophosphate
the stabilized carbanion
okay so let's here just draw a generic
ketose donor
okay
okay so this intermediate
is very similar to what we saw
for um the uh
when we did decarboxylation of the
alpha-keto acid
basically this same mechanism
would occur but rather than release co2
what gets released here instead
is this
shorter aldose
with two carbons that are lost and
remain here
on the active site of
of the enzyme on thymine pyrophosphate
okay now this molecule here then
needs to be transferred to a
so here we have our aldos
acceptor
foreign
okay
you
okay so that then will
regenerate tpp plus and of course
what we're left with is
our former aldos
which now becomes a
ketose that's
two carbons longer and so keto stoner
tpp plus breaks off the two carbons
releases the
that ketos two carbon shorter as an
aldose
those two carbons are then transferred
to an aldose acceptor
and it becomes two carbons longer and
becomes a ketose and so the net result
is is that we take
two carbons from the ketose donor give
them to the aldose acceptor
the ketos gets shorter by two carbons to
become
a shorter aldose and the former aldos
acceptor gets longer by two carbons to
become
a ketose and this is basically
repurposing very similar chemistry to
what we saw
for the decarboxylation of
alpha ketoacids okay
all right so that's how trans-ketolace
works
this is how trans aldolase works
and so
this works to move of course three
carbons
and so this is going to work much more
like what we saw
for
the aldolase reaction in glycolysis
okay so let's here
use our this here
is our generic
ketos donor so this is gonna be a donor
of
of three carbons
so active site lysine and transaldolase
you
you
you
okay so basically
this should look very familiar to you as
the mechanism for how
aldolase worked to break the
carbon-carbon bond to divide fructose
1 6-bisphosphate to glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate and dihydroxyacetone
phosphate
except in this case what we're left with
is
taking this ketos donor
and it releases on aldos that's three
carbon
shorter while retaining
bound to the enzyme the three carbons
from the keto stoner
just like we saw for the aldolase
reaction
now when we saw the aldolase reaction
glycolysis
of course we just um took this off the
molecule and that's how we ended up with
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate from the
bottom and dihydroxyacetone phosphate on
the top
the difference here is is now we're
going to
use this as a way to um combine it
move this three carbon unit rather than
just releasing it
transfer it over to an
aldos acceptor
you
you
okay and then
once we re
uh take the three carbon unit add it to
the aldose acceptor
you'll see that then you release this
now aldose three carbons longer as a
ketose
again very similar mechanism if you look
back on your notes to how
aldolase worked in glycolysis
and so the net effect of the
transaldolase reaction is is that we
take
three carbons from a ketose donor
we end up releasing three of the
the analdos that's three carbon shorter
take those three carbons transfer them
to an aldose acceptor
and now generate a ketose that is three
carbons
longer and so this
ultimately moves
two carbon units in the case of
trans-keto lace
three carbon units in the case of
transaldolase
it evolved this way because it's
repurposing existing chemistry
to allow these two and three carbon
swaps that ultimately
gives you the flexibility to build
a cycle like the calvin cycle where one
can
interconvert three carbon sugars and six
carbon sugars with five carbon sugars
and ultimately make that cycle
work and so on the calvin cycle this is
useful because
we can start with a five carbon ribulose
one five bisphosphate
and net generate a hexose as a storage
sugar
while regenerating our five carbon
ribulose one five bisphosphate
but it has an additional benefit and
that this is also a way to generate
five carbon sugars and so you can see
that
ribose 5-phosphate is one of the
intermediates
in the calvin cycle and of course ribose
is a useful
sugar to generate nucleoside so
all the time you spent talking about rna
and dna
um with professor yaffi you saw lots of
five carbon sugars lots of pentoses
as the ribose in those backbones and so
it's not just
you know now not just nucleosides it's
also
part of lots of cofactors nad fad
coenzyme a all of those cofactors
ended up having um nucleosides in them
right and so lots of ribose needed by
the cell
in order to make nucleosides and this is
a way to for at least photosynthetic
organisms the calvin cycle
a way for them to make ribose
to generate all those nucleosides
now that's great if you're a
photosynthetic organism because you can
run the calvin cycle and do it in a way
that you can store carbon for the night
uh as a some hexose that you can burn
later when you don't have light to carry
out the light reactions of
photosynthesis
or if you want to grow you can use it to
make nucleosides and replicate your
genome or make
rna or make ribosomes
and in fact the calvin cycle generating
ribose is a way to get those you'll see
when we get to this in a few lectures
that ribose 5-phosphate
is the starting point to generate um
both purine and pyrimidine nucleotides
however this reactions the calvin cycle
is unique to photosynthetic organisms
but of course
animals including us or all
non-photosynthetic organisms
also need to make ribose and we also
need a way to make
nadph and we need a source of nadph for
the same reason plants
needed it and that is we need something
to
have an nadph nadp ratio that's useful
to keep our glutathione reduced
that allows us to keep our cells in a
reducing state
battle reactive oxygen species help with
reductive biosynthesis we all know that
if we
eat too much food we can all store those
excess calories as fat fat is reduced
carbon
making the reduced carbon and the fatty
acids is going to
require a source of electrons all
organisms that source of electrons is
going to be nadph
which makes sense because an nadph nadp
ratio
that's more reduced can favor reduction
reactions
and in our next lecture we will see how
that's used to actually store
carbon as fat when there's excess
nadph around now
that makes a lot of sense but
obviously as non-photosynthetic
organisms
we as well as all non-photosynthetic
organisms can't rely on photosynthesis
in the calvin cycle and so we need
another pathway that allows us to do
uh both nadph production as well as a
ribose production and that's where we
get to
the pentose phosphate pathway
all right and so the pentose phosphate
pathway
the ppp also sometimes referred to
as the pentose phosphate shunt
is a major pathway that all organisms
photosynthetic and non-photosynthetic
can use to generate nadph
which is useful for cells as a source of
reducing power
as well as
ribose which is going to be necessary if
we're going to build
um nucleosides and
cofactors that contain nucleosides
all right now how
one runs the pentose phosphate pathway
to get these two
products is conceptually
akin to the calvin cycle
but it's a calvin cycle in reverse and
so if we look at
what really happens in the calvin cycle
all right we start with a five carbon
sugar
we add co2 we reduce it with
nadph and atp and we end up generating
a six carbon sugar and so the pentose
phosphate pathway
is we're going to start with a six
carbon
sugar we're gonna oxidize
to generate co2
and a 5 carbon sugar and if we oxidize
we're going to end up those electrons
have to go somewhere
and so we can net generate put those
electrons and net generate
nadph the calvin cycle
is of course doing reduction remember
reduced carbon is energy storage
oxidizing carbon is energy
release and so the calvin cycle we had
to put
energy in that energy of course came
from photosynthesis that's
the magic of us harvesting energy from
the sun
in order to do biology and so the
light products the nadph and atp came
from photosynthesis in order to net run
the calvin
cycle but just like we saw with
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis
if one direction of a pathway requires
energy input well the other direction is
going to be favorable
and so if we oxidize a six carbon sugar
to make a five carbon sugar in co2
that intuitively hopefully by now should
be favorable
and so we can use that energy release to
charge up an nad
ph to nadp ratio that now gives the cell
a source of reducing power okay so
energetically makes sense
now this pentose phosphate pathway is
also sometimes called a shunt
because really the way this works is as
a
branch of glycolysis a shunt of
glycolysis
if you will because it's an alternative
way to run glycolysis
and get nadph and
the so 6-phosphate remember for
glycolysis
we can isomerize to give us fructose
6-phosphate
and then ultimately in glycolysis
can generate glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
down to pyruvate which can go to the tca
cycle
et cetera et cetera et cetera okay
of course glucose is a six carbon sugar
fructose is a six carbon sugar
glyceraldehyde three phosphate is a
three carbon sugar
aldos ketose aldose okay
so if we take our glucose 6-phosphate
and we
send it into the pentose phosphate
pathway the pentose phosphate
shunt and rather than oxidize the
glucose as we did in glycolysis
we oxidize it to release co2
and generate a
five carbon sugar like a ribose
biphosphate
okay now we have a way to get
five carbon sugars pentoses by oxidizing
glucose six phosphate
all right those electrons have to go
somewhere
and so that ends up being
a way to generate
nad ph okay
once we get those five carbon sugars
that's great if we want to build
nucleotides
but it turns out we could also
run a bunch of transketolase and
transall the lace reactions
and interconvert five carbon sugars with
six carbon sugars and three carbon
sugars just as we did in the calvin
cycle
and if we run it this way you can see
that i can now make this
effectively an alternative version of
glycolysis a shunt if you will
start with glucose 6-phosphate rather
than going the traditional way
first go to make five carbon sugars and
then bring those
carbons back into glycolysis
that i can then further oxidize to
pyruvate
and oxidizing the tca cycle etc
and so all of this so glycolysis happens
in the cytosol
the pentose phosphate pathway happens in
the cytosol and really this can be
thought of
as two separate phases and so this
glucose 6-phosphate
going to
a pentose like ribose 5-phosphate
plus co2 that is referred to
as the oxidative
pentose phosphate pathway okay
okay
all right the oxidative pentose
phosphate pathway because it's using
oxidation of glucose carbon to generate
ribose 5-phosphate
and nadph
all right or this swaps here
between five carbon sugars and six
carbon sugars and three carbon sugars
very similar
to what we saw in the calvin cycle
which is really interconverting
six carbon and three carbon sugars
with five carbon sugars so that is
referred to
as the non-oxidative
pentose phosphate pathway
and it makes sense all those trans keto
lace and transaldo lace reactions that i
just
discussed with you in great detail no
electron movement
no oxidation reduction non-oxidative ppp
similar to the calvin cycle it's
interconverting
pentoses with trioses and hexoses
okay so this should be
very clear now that this
is actually a really useful
things for cells because having this
pentose phosphate pathway work
in these two different ways the
oxidative and the non-oxidative
give cells a lot of flexibility to make
pentoses when they need ribose to make
nucleosides
as well as nadph when they need
nadph to deal with say oxidative stress
right suppose you take
a drug causes oxidative stress in your
cells
pentose phosphate pathway can increase
as a way to make more
nadph okay so if the cell needs nadph
because there's oxidative stress
it can run the oxidative pentose
phosphate pathway
if it also needs to make ribose great it
has a short source of pentoses to make
ribose
however if it just needs nadph and not
ribose it can then take those ribose
carbons
re-enter them into glycolysis so
running this shunt allows you to get
nadph
as well as atp while oxidizing
glucose carbon however
if you need ribose and you don't need
nadph well forget the oxidative ppp
just take sugars from glycolysis and
shunt them over by the non-oxidative ppp
to make ribose and so you can run this
direction
if you need nadph and you can run this
direction
if you just need ribose all right
so
this is great because it gives cells
a lot of of of uh of
of a flexibility and so these two
pathways
really can be worked together
or they can work separately depending on
what the cell needs
and can really be tuned in a way to
allow
the cell to get um both ribose and nadph
and match it
as demands and so in a lot of ways it's
probably better to think of them
as two separate pathways a so-called
oxidative
ppp which is really glucose 6-phosphate
plus 2 nadp
plus generating 2
nadph
plus
um pentose
plus co2 all right and
a non-oxidative
ppp which is really
interconverting
three pentoses with two hexoses
and one triose
okay so three times five is
15 carbons two times six
is 12 carbons plus 3 carbons
15 carbons all right
this reaction oxidative ppp
is only going to be favorable in one
direction you would need a separate
pathway if you're going to run it the
opposite direction that doesn't
happen in in organisms so that's
under physiological conditions a one-way
pathway you can only go one direction
through the oxidative ppp in cells
whereas a non-oxidative ppp is just this
inner conversion of
trioses and hexoses with pentoses
this is very reversible just like
the calvin cycle would be very
reversible
and so while they can work together as i
described it's really useful to think of
them as separate pathways
and so let's go through each of them um
separately so you can see how they work
all right so let's start first with the
actually
so let's start first here with the
oxidative
pentose phosphate pathway and so
okay so this here would be alpha
glucose 6-phosphate okay
and so
okay so first step of the oxidative
pentose phosphate pathway
is we're going to oxidize the
one carbon of glucose that's of course
going to
have two electrons so if we oxidize that
carbon something else has to be reduced
that hydride ion those two electrons can
go to nadp plus
to make nadph reaction that we've now
seen a million times
that oxidizes the alcohol at carbon one
to
the um to the ketone and that gives us
this
lactone very similar to what we saw as
the first step in the epimerase reaction
when we described that
to give us this molecule
6-phosphogluconolactone
all right now so
in essence what this did remember is it
oxidized remember this
one carbon was the aldehyde of glucose
this now becomes on this lactone it's
actually an acid
and that becomes evident if we break
open
this ring here with water
okay that gives a cis molecule 6-phospho
glucanate oh i forgot to mention this
first reaction here is catalyzed by this
enzyme g6pd glucose 6-phosphate
dehydrogenase
makes sense oxidation reduction reaction
dehydrogenase
glucose 6-phosphate dehydrogenase just
as an aside for those of you interested
in medical school
turns out glucose 6-phosphate deficiency
in humans is actually a quite
common genetic disorder very common in
mediterranean regions
because it is thought to
have evolved because it confers some
resistance to
malaria and so having less g6pd
means you deal less well with oxidative
stress and as a result
some foods and drugs can cause increased
symptoms in those patients but also
having
that means that the cells are less
the cells are more resistant to malaria
infection because the
malaria ends up killing the cell before
it can establish an
infection because it causes some
oxidative stress
okay back to the pathway so if we open
up this lactone
what we have here is this molecule
6-phosphogluconate it's basically
glucose where the aldehyde is now
been oxidized to the acid that's how we
generated
nadph the next step is we're going to
oxidize carbon 3
okay so if we
oxidize
the alcohol on carbon 3
those electrons have to go somewhere
put them on the nad plus that gives us
nadph
this is catalyzed by six
phospho gluconate
dehydrogenase okay generates an nadph
and what ends up being generated is
this intermediate
if you look at this intermediate this
is a beta um
keto acid all right so here's our acid
that is
alpha beta to the
the ketone so a beta keto acid
remember decarboxylation of
beta-ketoacids is favorable
same trick that we saw before in the
tca cycle and other places
and so remember that generates
this enol and why it's so favorable
is because the enol prefers to
rearrange to the
keto form
okay and when we arrange the keto form
this of course is the pentose
ribulose 5 phosphate
okay and so ribulose 5-phosphate
of course we saw in the calvin cycle so
we started with phosphorylation at the
one position ribulose 1 5-bisphosphate
so ribulose 5-phosphate can be produced
by the oxidative pentose phosphate
pathway
glucose 6-phosphate first oxidize
the 1-carbon by g6pd
that generates six phosphogluconate
oxidized the three carbon
that allows favorable beta
decarboxylation to generate
another nadph and ribulose 5-phosphate
once you have that ribulose 5-phosphate
we can of course
use an isomerase
and with an isomerase we can
generate
ribose biphosphate
which is now available to be
sent to do nucleic acid synthesis
or we can use
on epimerase
and if we use an epimerase we can change
the stereochemistry
at this three position
and that gives me xylose 5-phosphate
which was the uh
keto stoner and acceptor for the
transketolase transalvalace reactions
that were so useful
for entering the non-oxidative
pentose phosphate pathway or
basically some version of the calvin
cycle and so
we can get ribose 5-phosphate xylose
5-phosphate ribulose 5-phosphate
all as products of the oxidative pentose
phosphate pathway
which will allow us to either generate
ribose as a way to
make nucleosides or have carbon in the
right form that i can now run the
oxidative pentose phosphate pathway and
have it
re-enter glycolysis okay
great so that's the oxidative pentose
phosphate pathway
now let's discuss the non-oxidative
pentose phosphate pathway which
just like the calvin cycle is
interconversion
of three carbon and six carbon sugars
with five carbon sugars basically it's
the calvin cycle same idea
transketolase transaldo lace obviously
it evolved from the calvin cycle because
photosynthesis
had to be first so let me first
put it in context how it works and then
we can draw it
in more detail
okay so this here is glycolysis
if i run the oxidative
pentose phosphate pathway
can generate two nadphs
as well as a
ribulose 5 phosphate
that ribulose 5-phosphate can be turned
into
ribose 5-phosphates
and xylose 5-phosphates
okay aldos and ketose
acceptors i can then
use these five carbon sugars if i do a
trans-keto lace reaction
i'll get a three carbon aldose
and a seven carbon
ketose okay remember trans-keto-lice
moves
two uh carbons from the
ketose to an aldose giving you a shorter
aldose and a longer ketose
all right now if i run
a transaldo lace reaction i'll move
three carbons
that gives me a six carbon ketose and a
four carbon
aldose if i
run another trans-keto lace reaction
with this four carbon sugar with this
five carbon sugar
i will then generate a another
six carbon ketose and a three carbon
aldose
these six carbon
are fructose six phosphate and this
3-carbon
aldosis glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate and i
can re-enter
glycolysis the stoichiometry works up
if i do this 3 times so 3 times 5
equals 15 carbons all right
so 3 ribulose 5-phosphates from the
oxidative ppp
if i turn them into one ribose
5-phosphate
and 2-xylose phosphate i can allocate
one here and one here
these two can come together to give me
one fructose-6-phosphate
and one erythrose4-phosphate that
erythrose4-phosphate
can use the other xylose 5-phosphate to
give me another fructose-6-phosphate
and the glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate such
that i have
2 hexoses and
1-triose coming from my
three pentoses and so
total here again of 15 carbons
okay and so like the calvin cycle
these trans-ketolase and trans-elderlace
reactions are all reversible
and so if i don't want to run the
oxidative pentose phosphate pathway i
can start with
fructose 6-phosphates and glyceraldehyde
3-phosphates from glycolysis
and run it this direction to generate
riboses in order to make
make nucleosides all right
just to be explicit about this
hopefully this all makes sense after the
long discussion we had of the calvin
cycle and how these reactions work and
you could work this out yourself
but i'll close today by just showing
this and how it works
i'll actually show it in the opposite
direction i described it here
moving from products of the oxidative
ppp
running through the non-oxidative ppp to
re-enter glycolysis
but i'm going to now draw it for you
starting with products of glycolysis
running the non-oxidative ppp in the
other direction
to generate pentoses just because
you know this is so reversible but also
point out to you
how this whole thing can work
all right so
here is a
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate from
glycolysis that's a
aldose acceptor
here's a fructose 6-phosphate
from glycolysis that can be a keto
stoner
and so if i run
a trans
keto lace reaction so remember
trans-keto lace transfer two carbons
from
the ketose to the aldos
what am i left with well i'm left with a
shorter aldose
okay this is erythros for phosphate
and i'm left with a longer ketose
there's a pentose xylose 5-phosphate
okay now i have my erythros
4-phosphate
and my fructose 6-phosphate
so if i now carry out a
transaldolase reaction so i'm going to
move three carbons now for my
ketostoner fructose 6-phosphate to my
aldos
acceptor and so what do i end up with so
i end up with a
this becomes three carbon shorter so
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
move the three carbons from the ketos to
the aldos acceptor now i end up with a
longer ketose
okay now i have the seven carbon
acetoheptulose
seven phosphate
if i now again run a
trans-keto lace reaction so
two carbons here um transferred from the
ketose
to the aldos what i end up with
now is a
five carbon xylose five phosphate
and
so aldos becomes a longer ketose by two
carbons
and
our
ketos becomes a shorter aldose
by two carbons which is a
a ribose 5-phosphate
i can now have 2
xylose 5-phosphates and a ribose
5-phosphate
i can take my xylose
5-phosphates and
carry out an epimerase reaction
if i carry out an epimerase reaction i
of course get
change the stereochemistry at the
three position
to get a
ribulose 5-phosphate
or i can carry out
an isomerase reaction
take my ribose biphosphate to ribulose
5-phosphate and so
if you note that i started this time
with products of glycolysis
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate fructose
6-phosphate did a series of
trans-ketolase and transalva lace
reactions
ultimately to generate
three so two fructose six phosphates one
glyceraldehyde three phosphate so that's
six plus six plus three equals fifteen
carbons i get
five three sorry three pentoses out
xylose 5-phosphate a ribose 5-phosphate
and axial
5-phosphate which i can then use a
pembrase or isomerase reactions to give
me
ribulose 5-phosphate which of course all
could be shuttled into ribose
5-phosphate giving me the flexibility
to start with products of glycolysis and
net generate ribose 5-phosphate for
nucleoside
synthesis if i run the oxidative pentose
phosphate pathway
i end up with ribulose 5-phosphates
i can take those ribulose 5-phosphates
turn them into xylose 5-phosphates and
ribose 5-phosphates
run the same series of trans-ketolace
and transalise reactions in reverse
and get glyceraldehyde 3-phosphates and
fructose-6-phosphates
either direction 15 carbons in 15
carbons out
can start with products of the oxidative
ppp and put them back in glycolysis
or start with products of glycolysis and
generate pentoses
such as ribose biphosphate for
nucleoside synthesis
giving cells a lot of flexibility to
take carbohydrates from glycolysis
and make pentoses for nucleosides as
well as have a way to generate
nadph i know there's a lot of
carbons moving around and a lot of
swapping but hopefully after today
how it works and why it works this way
is a little bit clearer than
if you just sit down and try to memorize
these really confusing pathways
okay next time we'll talk about how one
uses nadph as a source of reducing power
in all organisms in order to synthesize
fatty acids
thanks